quand l'homme s'est installé sur l'île
de la Réunion au 17e siècle la forêt
couvrait la totalité de la surface de
l'île malgré la grande quantité
d'espèces présentes aucune pratiquement
n'était comestible
et pourtant dans la forêt de basse
altitude jusqu'à 1200 m parmi les arbres
qui prospèrent sur les coules de lave
récente les fruits du bois de pommes
attirent nos sens et nos
papilles il peut atteindre 20 m de haut
mais on le trouve plus généralement
entre 4 et 8
m son écorce est lisse de couleur
grisâtre ou brun
rougeâtre branches se déploient à
l'horizontale occupant les espaces
disponibles de la
forêt les feuilles ovales et allongées
sont très pointu à l'extrémité elles
poussent de façon opposée et presque à
plat exhibant un maximum de surface à la
lumière jusqu'au mois de décembre les
fleurs apparaissent à l'extrémité des
rameaux accroché aux branches ou
directement sur le Tron les fleurs
s'épanouissent
partout il semble que le seul objectif
de la plante soit de se faire
remarqué dès le levé du soleil les
abeilles visitent inlassablement les
fleurs
grenas de nombreux cœurs roses s'ouvrent
et balancent doucement leurs étamines
dans le
vent les nombreux fr fruit qui en
résulte montre l'efficacité d'adaptation
de la plante aux animaux présents sur
l'île capable de féconder les
fleurs ils ressemblent fortement à de
petites pommes tant par leur forme que
par leur couleur et il est fort probable
que les premiers explorateur y est
croqué les apparences trompeuses du
fruit laissent perplexe le consommateur
dès la première bouchée le goût est
décevant acidulé et astringant très
légèrement sucré
le croquant de la pomme est complètement
oublié et remplacé par une consistance
spongieuse mais il est
comestible ça et là les fruits
alourdissent les branches mais la
majeure partie se situe sur le Tron
est-ce un moyen d'alléger l'arbre de ce
fardeau ou plutôt de faciliter l'accès à
des animaux plus gros capables de
festoyer de ces pommes au cœur de la
pulpe charnue de chaque fruit des
graines très petites se cachent et se
laisse aisément emporter dans le ventre
des animaux elles germeront plus loin au
hasard des pérégrinations des oiseaux le
bois de pomme fait partie des arbres qui
portent de gros fruits mais il est le
seul à posséder une chair comestible et
épaisse a-t-il été consommé par nos
aïeux il devait en tout cas être un plat
attendu par les perroquets et les
chauv-souris qui peuplit autrefois l'île
de la
Réunion